hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are going to react
to the Oscar nomination list because of
the way the media works I'm well aware
of at least one nomination hence the
pandering beany right here that's right
Black Panther Best Director Ryan Coogler
has been nominated Chadwick Boseman for
Best leading Actor Best Screenplay
adapted and original Michael B Jordan
for Best Supporting Actress I am so
excited to look at this list because you
know articles always lead with some
nominations so I saw that one right that
was the first one I saw Black Panther
nominated for Best ensemble and popular
category Eddy who let's let's get this
show on the road and see what we got
here the guy here we got here we got
here okay okay let's just go with the
big ones Best Picture let's do this it's
right here yeah a lot of B movies black
Klansmen I love that movie I think that
was in my top 10 I swap that with black
Klansmen was an amazing film awesome to
hear awesome to hear Black Panther it's
not gonna win but I'm going to dominated
honestly if that wins I'll be very
surprised I'd be very surprised and
that's the Avengers reassembling or
whatever they're saying at the Oscars I
like the Black Panther movie quite a bit
I feel like if the Oscars give it to
Black Panther then it will be a
confirmation that they truly do want to
satisfy the public or John why don't you
stop thinking with your white man
mentality and realize that it's the best
movie of the year
sure why not actually my favorite movie
the years a movie featuring many white
people star was born Bohemian
city yay I take back every criticism
I've ever given about that movie and the
shock I had at the Golden Globes I I am
so happy and I hope this stands a chance
the favorite is a movie that I will
always intend on watching and probably
never get around to honestly speaking I
really hope it I can I can squeeze it
and yeah well we'll see Green Book yay
racism is wrong and black Clanton's
similar message more in-your-face
package which one black uh yeah I could
be mistaken it could be the most low-key
mellow film here I guess it's saying the
KKK is wrong Roma I watched that last
night for the first time people just
last night the first time yeah the
feel-good movie of the year right there
Wow
just it's rare when you can get him
moving out days that blends comedy and
action all into one a little too much
CGI in its epic finale but great set up
for a franchise of this made
oh yeah well Spike Lee if Spike Jonze is
Spike Lee directed the show he did he
did both I never
I didn't think Spike Jonze likely could
bring together the authenticity of what
it's like being a maid in Mexico in the
70s so well I know but they pulled it
off man that was that was one hell of an
entertaining film it's a dream matchup
right there I'm glad it worked out and
yet tears of joy beginning to end a star
is born or as I call it a star is
snubbed yeah hey that's the talk of
stars born everywhere I mean you never
know maybe the Oscars will turn it
around and do exactly what the Golden
Globes didn't which is a war two stars
born for stuff yes super song I got a
revenge and it'll probably still take
smoke I actually intended on watching
vice last night but it's not out yet
on Amazon or streaming or anything like
that so instead I went with Romo but I
can from just if you watch that I didn't
see a trailer for Romo
but I did see a trailer for Vice and
after watching the trailer for Vice I
can certainly tell you Romo is probably
twice as energetic as anything vice has
to offer yeah Adam McKay is usually a
pretty low-key director very low-key
best Elector directors alfonso quran
directed rome oh that's who directed
Romo I'm sorry it wasn't a pair of
spikes and my bad I should know that I
watched the comedy last night yeah no
they should give awards for his best
credits then maybe we would all watch
and catch those names well honestly Romo
has the longest opening credits you will
ever see oh boy that's what I'm really
looking forward to you know how much I
love credits the favorite oh you're gosh
lamb Tomas what a name black clansmen
it's likely you know I didn't really
like the way he directed black Klansmen
that's for sure
Adam McKay vice that makes sense the
hell is cold war paavo public has heard
of cold war
I've heard of cold war I don't know much
of anything about it but I remember the
week he came out and it was on Tomatoes
coming this week yeah just cool the days
the only sincere part of the video I'm
always kind of happy when they put in
somebody you wouldn't expect I guess and
and you know what that tells me is that
that must be a pretty solidly directed
movie because the rest of these have
something else to write on besides just
the movie not to take away from them but
you know it's like vice hasn't gotten
the most unanimous praise even though
Adam McKay is directed and he's probably
got a pretty distinct style so I feel
like Cold War probably earned its way
into this category pretty hard sure sure
perhaps yes I'm always fascinated by
movies that have a major consideration
for like this is like this is one of the
top considerations for what could
potentially win Best Picture
I feel like a star is born as one of the
talks
Bradley Cooper's not the service
director and I that is my favorite
directed movie of the year and I forgot
to mention at the top of this video that
was the other article I saw the headline
Bradley Cooper could be for the acting
awards though you never do I knew be for
director I actually don't know who the
best actor or actress nominations are
here we go Best Actress
yelitza up buried aroma like I said man
it's good that an action leading role is
finally getting its due the wife was the
other movie I was looking for last night
I really want to watch I feel like at
this point it's a tight you know based
off the amount of love that Romo is
getting I wouldn't be surprised if you
actually won the award she's she's
amazing in that movie she really is yeah
that is like feel sorry for me the movie
[Laughter]
it's such a no it's so like
subtly authentic from beginning to end
Olivia Colman the favorite Lady gaga
three stars
I mean props to Olivia Colman though
because she has been holding it down and
so many like character parts that you've
seen in so many British flicks and shows
over time that like I'm glad to see her
getting a lot of recognition for this
particular role she's actually one of
the main reasons I want to see that
movie cuz she's really great across
drama comedy whatever so I'm just um
throw bird alright John like you got you
got the Coleman fan base down there and
Lady gaga
yeah yeah I love her music Melissa
McCarthy for can you ever forgive me you
know with this performance and the happy
time murders in the same year she's
killing it right dude this is just
nominated her for both of those movies
in this one category I really feel like
you know Lady Gaga is probably the one
that the audiences are like win but I
feel like it's probably gonna be a
pretty tight race it's been going and
you'll it so yeah I mean especially
after the Golden Globes and everybody
being surprised
yeah best actor look out Christian Bale
for vice Bradley Cooper for a star was
born
- nub on snugged it saw its word in your
Dean that's cool
you know they were in a place beyond the
pines together and shared a lot of
screen time in that movie and now
they're going toe-to-toe with one
another and Christian Bale is definitely
gonna win that one welcome to foe and
eternities gate I have not seen a single
clip or trailer for that movie I just
hear great things yeah Dafoe man Remy
Malick oh this is that's the audience
one right there that's the one everyone
wants to win you're out there
I feel like Christian Bale could edge
this category out at the Oscars maybe
but you know I argue rami malek
I feel like Christian Bale will win I
kind of get that sense yeah I really do
i I mean to me it's like okay it's a
tyrant rami malek and Christian Bale
come on like I really feel like
Christian Bale will be the one who wins
yeah Vigo Vigo I'm actually really glad
his performance is getting a lot of
recognition because it's so different
than anything I've seen Viggo Mortensen
he's very charming I mean he definitely
left it I even as much as I don't love
that movie as much as the Golden Globes
did I thought he left a huge impression
on me from that film he's so funny in
that movie yeah he slips effortlessly
into that role and yeah after seeing him
play so many other more broad things to
see him dead I almost just feels real
and after the hands of a different
director it would have been an
over-the-top performance but he it was I
feel like him and Farrelly really knew
the tone yeah yeah funny considering you
know so much of Peter Farrelly's other
work is broad comedy yeah best
supporting actress Amy Adams for vice
hell yeah
marina tavira Roma she is good
Regina King I feel like Regina King
probably has the best shot here really
yeah I mean the problem is you got two
favorites in this category
we cancel each other out with Emma Stone
Rachel vice uh-huh and and yeah I don't
know I feel like Regina King probably
stands a solid chance I mean like people
everybody loves Amy Adams I haven't
heard like specifics about her in this
movie and I feel like yeah the lead in
Romo will probably be the one who all
right well best supporting actor right
here we got Herschel Olli Olli
who is Gro thank God Adam drivers
getting recognition for that sucks for
the Washington actor okay so as I was
putting inserts in this video I realized
that for the star of black clansmen we
said the name Isaiah Washington and
actually we're gonna just keep it that
way you know and now make the white guy
black well you know I've heard he's
quite good well I I will admit they're
like as great as I thought Isaiah
Washington was in black Klansmen the guy
who got like the most emotional range to
demonstrate in black Klansmen was Adam
driver so that does make sense
Sam Elliott first stars born whoo they
deem that snub at the Golden Globes
that's what we all really were hoping
for is Sam Elliot would get recognized
for his work of that movie Richard II
grant can you ever forgive me if you win
that awesome no idea what that is Sam
Rockwell for vice I've heard he is
really good in that movie let's move on
Best Original Screenplay the favorite
the favorite you know Oscars love their
political dramas yeah appear all period
piece but I've also heard it's like wild
and it's about them all kind of behaving
poorly and it's not the political
journal you would expect it to be yeah I
really is but it also isn't yeah we'll
see John maybe that's when you're like
filmmaker friends same film things sure
just keep it real that's right first
reforms funniest movie of the year Paul
Schrader just that one movie that I fear
I won't see but I hear his amazing green
book Roma Vice his vice really like this
based on
life and probably several biographies I
mean I feel like the Roma movies so much
and it's more of its direction and
editing and all the technical stuff it's
just such a super quiet but maybe those
are the most impressive writing jobs
because it's all vice rata McKay yeah
he's got them dialogue best adapted
screenplay a star is born you know I was
thinking about it the the fact that a
stars weren't is the fourth version is
probably a thing that is a slight
hindrance towards consideration for it
even though it's so different than the
other ones in a lot of ways like more
ways than one
um it I feel like there is a slight
hindrance towards it because of that
well yeah I mean it's basically you can
easily argue we've seen this story
several other times even though it is
different it's like the earmarks the arc
is the same color yeah and so yeah I'm
sure that there are a lot of people who
are like you know damn look at Netflix
killing it the battle ballad of Buster
Scruggs good for them you expect the
cone sing in nomine abuse tariqa talk
makes sense never heard of can you ever
forgive me oh that's the one my bad okay
I know the image of Melissa McCarthy
heard a I've heard that was pretty good
too
I don't know gonna win this category but
yeah I root for her when she changes
though best makeup and inheritors on the
re movies nominated yeah that always
confuses me when they do this because
there are enough movies with solid
makeup and hair styling to nominate at
least when you throw your comic book
[ __ ] yeah
yeah where's black pants that's sure
it's crazy how Black Panthers got a Best
Picture nod and yet it's a very makeup
in heroine having so much makeup and
hair both on a sci-fi level and on just
a naturalistic control yeah they had a
lot of practical designs with bringing
the culture life in that movie I'm
I actually am pretty surprised it's not
in here yeah maybe they are there only
three movies yeah I don't get when that
HAP
I can't imagine there are only three
movies where makeup and hairstyling were
notable this year I did shave I haven't
even seen destroyer but the makeup on
freakin Nicole Kidman's face yeah even
though that's not flashy as much as you
know like an alien is or something like
that that's still impressive makeup work
and arguably the stuff that you don't
notice as well that's more naturalistic
yeah kind of more impressive in ways I'm
actually pretty surprised you'd think
that like when you look at the best
picture nods you would think that at
least Black Panther look at a nomination
or something it seems like they just
burned two spots and I can't occur what
the hell's up with that best costume
design okay but Black Panthers here that
makes said there's plenty of like makeup
aesthetic
The Ballad of bus or Scruggs of k'i that
make western the favorite obviously
that's the most obvious of them all how
does it it's costume and the name of the
genre Queen of Scots obviously Mary
Poppins Returns off see like I'm not I'm
not opposed to the obvious one because
clearly they deserve it yeah and to me
I'm like there's so much makeup in Black
Panther graffiti
Best Cinematography rum a better be here
rum is definitely here oh dang he shot
it himself
yeah a star is born
but not directing okay
they gotta look up with this cold war
movie is you never look away what movies
here I haven't heard Caleb Deschanel is
that the father of Zooey Deschanel I
believe maybe this is famous in
photographers so I got imagine that's
pretty cool yeah I mean it you could see
his great work through his daughter Oh
totally
all that camera that she is Best
Original Song Kendrick Lamar you finally
got your nomination okay the to me okay
you got what RBG alright Mary Poppins
returns
stars born by Ides it to me it's gotta
be a shallow or all this I feel like
they would just pull that yeah because
it would that would be their way of
giving Black Panther or the costume
design but I really feel like they're
gonna go with period piece for the
costume design and I feel like they
always go with period piece and I and I
wonder if this will be the time where
they take an easy one where they're like
oh this is the easiest way to make a
woke choice at this year's Oscars
is you know is to pasar sign costume
design for a black panther know I feel
like this is the one place the star is
born really has the the contention you
know think so yeah I mean people really
like all the stars and stuff like that
but I don't know the Black Panther
soundtrack and what the music is two
stars born are just different to me so I
feel like because shallow is also like
such an emotionally resonant part of
that movie and a focal part of that the
actual text of the movie I think it has
a pretty good chance yeah we'll see John
the Best Original Score Black Panther
this I can see black Angela Landsman
black people Mary Poppins returns okay
yeah I don't remember any of those songs
I feel like Mary Poppins I kind of hope
like fans I could take that ooh I heard
about free solo I heard that was a
crazy-ass documentary and RBG is a
documentary with Bader Ginsburg
documentary which I believe is still
playing at one of the museum's downtown
so like it's okay an impact
oh that's cool yeah that movie on the
basis of saying is a fictionalized won't
you be my neighbor and three identical
strangers is all here because without a
doubt those were the two I heard the
video is not about yeah a year yeah yeah
I am very surprised as well I'm
surprised at least will you be my
neighbor isn't on here but then again I
haven't seen these other four
documentaries maybe the Oz or five
documentary but I did see won't you be
my neighbor Best Animated Feature Ralph
breaks the Internet spider-man inspired
verse better win Best Foreign Language
Film Wow
Romo again I would be so happy if it
would both even though the for sure Romo
is not on my top ten list last year yeah
I would be I find that very entertaining
yeah Tony 18 goes bankrupt best sound
mixing Hey look there's the first man
nomination rightfully so actually I I
honestly might choose that or or I I
mean I haven't seen Romo yet but I a
first man I think has some really
impressive technical elements especially
in the south oh definitely like pant the
best sound yeah I feel like I put a
quiet place so in this category think so
just because of how much the dynamic
between sound and not sound played into
that movie and how much it physically
touched everybody who saw that more like
everybody who talked about a quiet place
was like I've never heard theaters quiet
and then the use of sound too though
this is the thing is like as much as
there isn't sound there's also a lot of
strategic sound in that movie so I feel
like it is the most kind of interesting
sonic movie without being in your face
with music and all sorts I'll meet you
halfway I feel like I feel like a quiet
place should win I don't feel like it
will win okay what do you think will
clearly Bohemian they kept playing the
tracks a'queen when they put on the
karaoke they didn't play all of the song
they had to edit it at Todd's true they
did I'd have cut them down to make them
fit the time of the film which Gio takes
a lot of missing
yeah I think it would be a toss-up
between first man or Roma honestly I
think that's that funny that like first
man is such a distinct movie in a lot of
ways and it's only been recognized so
far for sale which is just not the first
thing I would have thought of when I
thought a first man production design
okay
oh okay first man very pop and Roma
black panther okay well I I guess black
panther should win that for like I feel
like it would be should win yeah yeah
probably I mean you know Mary Poppins
for traditionalism but yeah I would go
with Black Panther best visual effects
alright here we go my category which one
has the most effects Avengers infinity
war Christopher Robin first man ready
player one solo I would be so tickled if
Christopher Robin like you know was most
impressive the way that Winnie the Pooh
came to life stole that balloon Irene's
that I would be happier if I guess I
wouldn't give it to ready player one I
mean I feel like infinity war arguably
should get it arguably I guess infinity
war is the most kind of high caliber
visual effects movie on this list that
also doesn't I feel like ready player
one relies on the CG and so does solo a
lot more than it has like story under
some kind of gripping drama underneath
it to really make it worthwhile whereas
Avengers infinity war has some very
prominent CGI that's both impressive and
also very much kind of serves the movie
beyond just oh cool like a lot of pop
culture stuff yeah need CG for this best
film editing okay okay I I'm gonna give
it to you know honestly as much as I'm
not a fan of this movie I would give it
to Bohemian Rhapsody and there's some
yeah there's some nifty editing choices
in there not because I think it's the
best edited movie oh but because of the
shooting experience that movie had with
switching Harsin to having to have this
all flow would make sense I'm sure
that's actually I'm sure a replacement
director and editor were like yeah I
imagined it probably in that disposition
that's actually that's a good call I
feel like maybe but I I feel like
personally advice would probably win
that one just judging by the other short
and how kinetic yeah distinct that
movies editing style was I would bet the
best and I made it short Oh easily one
small step Best live action short easily
fo fo-fo I've loved it love fo Best
Documentary short Oh easily period end
of sentiment er II about a vendor's end
game it's the pre making of what are you
talking about it's gonna be the best
alright guys well there you have it the
best picture we'll definitely be going
to Roma hey man you never know they
could surprise you they could I don't
know is like such an oscar movie and I
entered every every calorie that you can
imagine okay okay it's it there's a
point it's you know how I've said before
how movies that'll make me cry are the
ones that kind of have like layers of
like life and love and then sad like
it's layered yeah they've got emotional
dynamic they're disappointing Roma or
it's just like oh this is like just so
sad as it keeps getting sadder I get
less emotional because this is so sad
that I'm like I feel like in another
movie I probably be crying right about
now but this is just this is just a
really depressing feeling not stop I'm
just so used to it being sad
and I cry I'm excited for this
experiences oh yeah
it's a slow-moving slice of life and new
wave yeah anyway what do you guys think
will win better yet what got snubbed for
you huh [ __ ] Jake Gyllenhaal for
Nightcrawler you know who else who else
is the famous snubz we got a everybody
gets well Michael Keaton I'm going on
mobile Isis Thursday and I I haven't
gotten my questions for it yet mmm-hmm
I have a feeling one of the questions
will be about Oscar snubz and I know Dan
Merle is gonna go for Toni Collette for
hereditary know of course yeah maybe if
I get the questions first
that would be such chaos
you can't put out the video until you
get the question or otherwise he's gonna
see he's gonna watch it he's gonna know
or I would argue for a Best Director
four stars born that would be my biggest
one how can you get but can you be Tony
cool how can you get three acting
nominations Best Picture nomination and
somehow not acknowledge the directing of
them and Best Cinematography this is all
the director composing all of this find
all these categories the director must
have done something to orchestrate that
entire thing yeah yeah sure so yeah I
would definitely go with the stars born
for that anyhow yeah what are your board
of the snubs that really upset you
comment below subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
sayonara bye bye